beef Wellington von Gordon Ramsey das
wahrscheinlich bekannteste Gericht vom
bekanntesten Koch der Welt ein zartes
Stück Rinderfilet umhüllt von einer
duxell aus Pilzen einem kreb und
gebacken in einem knusprigen
blätterteigmantel genau das durften wir
essen in London im savoo Grill aber
warum waren wir überhaupt in London wir
haben eine unfassbare futur für euch
gedreht die in den nächsten Tagen auf
meinem Kanal kommen wird wirklich sehr
sehr geil unbedingt abchecken an der
Stelle lohnt sich auch mal ein Abo
dazulassen aber wieder zu unserem
Restaurant besesuch ab dem allerersten
Moment war das ein Besuch wie kein
anderer der service on point und all das
gipfelte darin dass wir sogar in die
Küche schauen durften und die Atmosphäre
dort werde ich auf jeden Fall so schnell
nicht vergessen alle hoch konzentriert
arbeiten daran das perfekte Produkt für
jeden Gast abzuliefern aber jetzt genug
der langen Worte machen wir uns auf den
Weg ins
[Musik]
Restaurant
wie unglaublich sieht hier das bitte
alles aus wir haben ein Rolls-Royce hier
stehen alles ist silber vertafelt
irgendwie fühle ich mich auch direkt ein
bisschen unwohl das ist so ein Ort der
sehr sehr sehr viel Luxus versprüht und
wir sind mehr oder weniger spontan hier
gelandet hier links ist schon das
Restaurant einfach reinlaufen so wird
man dazu gehören wirkich die Leute hier
sind glaube ich dieses ganz andere Level
rich guck gleich mal nach was hier eine
Nacht im Hotel kostet ich glaube 1000
bestimmt für eine Nacht normales Zimmer
fast 1000 € die Nacht und am besten
schläft man trotzdem zu Hause zumindest
wenn man eine Emma Matratze hat Emma
dürftet ihr ja von mir schon kennen ich
habe vor über einem Jahr meiner Freundin
Lara ein Bett von Emma geschenkt und mir
selbst auch letztens eine neue Matratze
zugelt bei Emma könnt ihr aktuell wieder
mit meinem Code Max dreams 5% on top
spannen das heißt bei dies die sowieso
schon bis zu 50% haben noch mal 5% extra
dafür müsst ihr einfach nur den QR Code
scannen und dieser Code ist gültig in
Deutschland Österreich und der Schweiz
aktuell sind die Emma black weeks die
bis zum 30 November 2023 geh für mich
persönlich ist es wirklich unglaublich
wichtig Eric kann das bestätigen gut zu
schlafen denn wir verbringen ein Drittel
unseres gesamten Lebens im Bett und wir
investieren alles andere warum also
nicht in unseren Schlaf ach ja der
Premium Topper den ihr ganz einfach auf
eure Matratze legen könnt wird übrigens
um 50% reduziert sein ich habe
mittlerweile auch nicht nur eine
Matratze von Emma sondern auch
Bettwäsche Bettbezüge und es sind
einfach gute Produkte ich schlaf darin
super gut bin immer erholt und fit um
für euch die Videos zu drehen außerdem
bietet Emma aber auch Boxspringbetten
Lattenroste Topper also wirklich alles
was für ein guten Schlaf nötig ist an
das Beste daran ist die Lieferung der
Matratze ist kostenlos ihr könnt 100
Tage probechlafen hab 10 Jahre Garantie
auf den Matratzenkern und die Bezüge
sind abnehmbar und waschbar was will man
also mehr also klickt auf den Link in
der Infobox Scan den QR Code und nutzt
den Code Max dreams der ist übrigens für
6 Monate gültig um euch guten Schlaf
nach Hause zu holen
hallo
per
ja das ist ein besonderer Ort das kann
man auf jeden Fall sagen ja wir sind
hier wirklich mehr oder weniger
reingestolpert weil eigentlich wollten
wir in ein sternestaurant von Gordon
Ramsey gehen wir haben uns aber nicht
geantwortet und dann habe ich gedacht
okay ich will eigentlich eh viel lieber
das Wellington Testen der lukas ist ja
auch in London wenn wir hier gerade hier
sind und er hat auch ein Wellington
getestet aber nicht das von Gordon
sondern das vermeintlich beste der Stadt
bin gespannt was uns heute hier erwartet
also es hat mich sofort geerdet als ich
hier reingekommen bin ich war so wow
jetzt beginnt was besonderes auch der
ist direkt so diskret professionell
freundlich es gibt ja gehobene
Restaurants wo du dich wie ein
Fremdkörper fühlst ne weil die Leute das
Gefühl geben du bist vielleicht nicht
unsere normale Kundschaft hier ist das
ganze so professionell auch wenn wir
jetzt weil wir spontan hier gelandet
sind vielleicht ein bisschen rausfallen
ne so mit einem vi leicht ein oversiz
Pulli oder so ganz freundlich und machen
alles möglich für uns und fühlt sich
sehr wohl thank you very much also
erfreulich bezahlbar ich habe kurz
gedacht das wird jetzt richtig richtig
teuer hier drin zweigang lunchmenü
kostet VI 54 P 3 Gang 60 P und wenn man
das Beef Wellington nimmt zahlt man 25
Pf Aufpreis seid wenn man seit dazu
möchte Kosten noch mal 8 p 50 extra 100
P pro Person mit Trinkgeld und das ist
natürlich unfassbar viel Geld ne weil
Fund auch noch mal ein bisschen mehr
wert ist als Euro aber das ist eine
Erfahrung schon jetzt unter diesem
Kronleuchtern in diesem festsal zu
sitzen also ich freue mich sehr schön
mal wieder so eine Restaurant Erfahrung
hier mit euch teilen zu können weil es
braucht natürlich auch immer ein Anlass
und was für einen besseren Anlass könnte
es geben als dies dieses besondere Lunch
hier in London ein
wunderwunderschönes Steak Tat aus
Rinderfilet relativ kleine Portion die
uns aber sehr gelegen kommt weil
dreigang Menü Z Mittag ist schon nicht
ganz wenig dazu haben wir ein bisschen
eigelbkonfie also diese gelben Pünktchen
oben drauf und sehr kunstvoll platzierte
grüne Sachen keine Ahnung was das ist
dazu gibt es eine gesmokete Butter sehr
sehr kunstvoll angerichtet und wenn man
an der Haube hier riecht kriegt man
wirklich eine kräftige Rauchnote schne
sich wer es gedacht tatsächlich wie
Butter und dazu gibt es jetzt ein klein
wenig Tat für diesen perfect bite wie
mein alter Freund W zer sagen würde
probieren
[Musik]
wir wow schmilzt im Mund tatal ist ja im
Prinzip Ros Rinderfilet aber es ist so
zart und so gut verarbeitet dass es
wirklich keinen Widerstand hat das
konfierte Eigelb ist wie so eine Creme
die das ganze umschließt und die Zunge
ummantelt Brot Steak
Tatar wirklich eine syfonie des
Geschmack und dann ist etwas passiert
womit ich niemals gerechnet hätte unser
Kellner dennis hat gesagt dass wir jetzt
sofort für einen Moment in die Küche
gehen könnten plötzlich stand ich
inmitten einer Hektik und
Professionalität wie ich sie in Küchen
selten gesehen habe alles hatte seinen
Ort und seinen Platz jeder wusste genau
wohin er laufen muss und dann habe ich
es gesehen es wurde wenig gequatscht
oder generell gesprochen das einzige was
man immer wieder gehört hat
war und der klare Fokus liegt auf den
beef Wellington 50% der Tische bestellen
ist und in der Woche wird es über 400
Mal verkauft und jetzt ist es endlich
auch für uns soweit wunderschön thank
you very much es ist einfach vor uns
jetzt steht es hier ohne Witz ist das
erste Mal dass ich aber auch überhaupt
in einem Restaurant bin wo es beef
Wellington auf der Karte gibt die
meisten von euch die auf das Video
geklickt haben haben drauf geklickt weil
man das Hal kennt irgendwie aber es
gibt's trotzdem nicht bei uns Bild
hübsch das Rinderfilet ist medium rare
Imp Perfektion außenherum ist diese
duxell die ich auch schon paar mal
selbst gemacht habe also eine pilzpasta
aus der die Feuchtigkeit rausgekocht
wird dann wird das von einem grünen kreb
ummantelt wo wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
Spinat mit drin ist und dann haben wir
eben diese wunderschöne
blätterteigchicht die das ganze
einschließt in der das ganze gart s dass
der gesamte Geschmack konserviert wird
das liegt auf wildbrokkoli und
kartoffelpüe welches so kunstvoll auf
den Teller gespritzt wurde mit einem
Spritzbeutel ich glaub das ist das
schönste Kartoffelpüree was ich jemals
gegessen und gesehen habe ich red glaube
ich nicht lange rum ich probi zu
allererst einmal das Kartoffelpüree
nehme das hier mal runter es wurde
wahrscheinlich mindestens einmal durch
ein feinieb durchgepresst damit diese
Konsistenz
erhält sehr feiner sahniger Geschmack
aber ich bin für eine Sache hierher
gekommen wow guck mal wie diese dxell
steht
unglaublich wirklich rund um rosa das zu
essen ist noch mal eine Kunst für sich
hier haben wir den perfekten weit
Rinderfilet düxell spinatcrep und
[Musik]
Blätterteig man schmeckt jede einzelne
Komponente man merkt dass das dieingen
hier in Perfektion gemacht wird die
einzigen Male die ich belenken gegessen
habe ist wenn ich es auch selbst gemacht
habe und ich weiß wie unglaublich
anstrengend schwierig und langwierig das
ist und deshalb weiß ich so sehr zu
schätzen dass man das hier einfach
bestellen kann und diese traumhafte
nahzu perfekte Ausführung davon bekommt
hier steht jetzt unser Dessert vor mir
und es sieht einfach wieder wunderschön
aus so ein kleiner Staub der ein Hauch
von Imperfektion gibt weil ansonsten ist
wieder alles geometrisch perfekt mich
wundert dass sie keinen Stern haben hier
weil es ist ja wirklich so perfekt alles
vielleicht wollen Sie nicht es soll ja
auch Restaurants geben die wollen den
Stern gar nicht
haben man hat wirklich das Gefühl dass
man nicht nur Gordon Ramsey erlebt hat
sondern dass man auch London erlebt hat
wir musst ein bisschen Geld in die Hand
nehmen mit ein paar Getränken sind wir
hier bei 215 P für mich persönlich nicht
nur weil ich ein Video gemacht habe gut
investiertes Geld das eine tolle
Erfahrung und hat umso mehr Spaß gemacht
es mit euch zu teilen deshalb wenn euch
das Video gefallen hat lst gerne ein
Like da ein Abo da für uns geht's jetzt
leider wieder nach
Hause